c'est une première depuis 2013 il n'y
aura pas d' abattoir mobile cette année
sur ce terrain si tu attrapes dans la
zone d'activités desbruyères saint
quentin en yvelines a décidé de ne pas
reconduire l'opération provisoire
l'agglomération havok des nuisances au
niveau du voisinage et une charge
financière trop importante sur un
dossier qui coûterait entre 200 milles
et 300000 euros avec les difficultés que
nous connaissons dans la raréfaction des
dotations de l'état
on n'a plus les mêmes moyens alors il
serait assez paradoxal qu'on en arrive à
envisager la fermeture d'équipements
publics et que l'on continue à assurer
cette manifestation et cette charge
financière
donc je pense que c'est une réseau de
logique et de bon sens chaque année près
de mille cinq cents moutons étaient
proposés à la vente au marché au vif
pour cette fête religieuse
les animaux étaient ensuite sacrifié
suivant les rites devant les familles
un système qui fonctionnait selon les
associations musulmanes
on a connu des abattages sauvages dans
les années 80 90 on a trouvé enfin une
solution stable
d'un point de vue sanitaire et
sécuritaire on comprend pas qu'en 2017
une situation aussi intéressante aussi
bien pour les musulmans que pour les
pouvoirs publics puissent s'arrêter
l'abattoir mobile le plus proche se
trouve désormais à dreux à plus de 50 km
pour montrer leur mécontentement le
collectif cam 78 a lancé une pétition
courante
actuellement on est à 887 signature en
ligne
on a plus d'un millier de signatures
papier qui complètent ceux là on est en
tout cas plus de 2000 signatures au
total et on a un texte qui explique de
manière très détaillée l'historique de
l'abattoir et la particularité du loupé
de cette année la communauté musulmane
espère désormais trouver un compromis
avec les élus pour organiser l'événement
à saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'année
prochaine